favorite taylor swift album i mean i
like all i really like a lot of her
songs kim kardashian is getting candid
about taylor swift and playing coy about
her boo pete davidson who's your
favorite snl cast member
um
what a setup what a setup barry the 41
year old reality star is an open book
during her interview on the honestly
with barry weiss podcast where she dives
into a number of topics kim admits to
really liking taylor swift's songs
despite their past beef you'll recall
the kkw beauty founder famously had
drama with a shake it off singer back in
2016 stemming from this lyric and kim's
then-husband kanye west's track famous i
feel like me and taylor might still have
sex why i made that famous goddamn i
made that famous at the time taylor
slammed the lyric and kim clapped back
by sharing footage on keeping up with
the kardashians of a chat between taylor
and kanye that taylor didn't know was
being recorded during their conversation
the singer tells kanye she's okay with
the song but she later explained kanye
was never clear about specifically
calling her that [ __ ]
fast forward to 2021 when kim was asked
about taylor during the podcast she only
had positive things to say favorite
taylor swift album i mean i like all i
really like a lot of her songs
like they're all super cute and catchy
and i'd have to look in my phone to get
a name and that echoes what the mom of
four told et in 2009 number one song on
my ipod taylor swift's love story i love
taylor swift i'm the biggest taylor
swift fan and on the topic of music she
also revealed her favorite kanye albums
i really like yeezus
just because it's like
you know when you're there and you're in
it and you're you know what i mean
like you you see from start to finish um
i really love my beautiful dark twisted
fantasy also
but then kim who's usually very open
about her personal life got very shy
when asked who her favorite snl star is
who's your favorite snl cast member
uh
what a setup what a setup barry you know
who it is
the keeping up star and comedian have
been seeing each other for more than a
month now after the pair was spotted
holding hands at not scary farm in
october and most recently they
celebrated pete's 28th birthday together
rocking matching pjs alongside kim's mom
chris and rapper flavor flav who sat
down with e.t earlier this week and
revealed kim orchestrated the whole
thing for pete's special day pete
davidson loves himself some flavor flav
everything he does is flavor flavor
there's flavor flavor that flavor flavor
there's flavor flavored that so kim said
okay well for your birthday you're gonna
have flavor flav
so she sent for me
and that's how i ended up there you know
what i'm saying is this relationship
real what's going on with him
well see let me say this when it comes
down to pete davidson and kim
kardashian's relationship you know what
i'm saying
only them two know it best